je pense qu'il faut dans le pays des
lumières et de pasteurs qu'on arrête
d'avoir des espèces de débat permanent
sur les faits ou la vérité scientifique
et un conseil scientifique qui joue un
rôle essentiel
il va d'ailleurs être pérennisé je
remercie ses membres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
à
vous avez une cacophonie maintenant
entre les réponses qui sont donnés par
le ministère de la santé et le conseil
scientifique
[Musique]
m
pour que le conseil scientifique il est
dans son rôle qui est technique
nous serons dans le nôtre qui est
démocratique politique au sens plein du
terme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à